LANE SHACKLETON: Thank you so
much for coming to the last
session of Google I/O. We
understand that we're the only
thing standing between
you and happy hour.
So we're going to try to
keep this interesting.
My name is Lane.
I'm a product manager on
monetization at YouTube and
this is A.J.
A.J. CRANE: Hey,
I'm A.J. Crane.
I'm the product manager
for YouTube Channels.
LANE SHACKLETON: Cool.
So for the next 40 minutes, this
is what we're going to
talk about.
First we're going to talk
about some interesting
statistics and why your business
should be on YouTube.
Secondly, we're going to talk
about three examples of
businesses that are creating
great content that feels a lot
like the rest of the content
on YouTube and not like
traditional commercials.
And then we're going to bring
up a special guest from the
audience to demo how you can get
set up with your presence
on YouTube once you have
that great content.
And then, finally, we'll
answer some questions.
OK.
So let's get started.
First I want to just kick
off with a stat.
So recently, we announced that
we have a billion visitors on
YouTube every month.
So if you think about it,
it's pretty astounding.
There are about 2 billion
connected internet users
around the world.
So we have one in two of those
internet connected users
visiting the site every month.
And it's clearly not just
a US phenomenon.
So about 70 percent of
our visitors come
from outside the US.
Cool.
So we know there's a huge
audience on YouTube.
I don't think that number is a
huge surprise to anyone here.
But what are they doing?
Well, they're watching video.
And they're also
sharing video.
So every minute, about
700 videos get
shared on Twitter alone.
So in the course of the next
40 minutes, about 28,000
videos will be shared.
So we know that sharing
happens on Twitter.
We know it happens on email.
We know it happens on other
social properties.
And it happens on YouTube.
So people are, this huge
audience is watching.
And they're sharing.
Right.
So users are watching,
and they're sharing.
But how do we continue as a
platform to get great content
on YouTube?
So a key to making the long
term, a key to making this
ecosystem work in the long
term is making sure that
partners, those people that
actually create the content
that you watch, can make
a living off of this.
Can bring their content to
YouTube, quit their day jobs
and do what they love.
So recently we announced that
we have over 1,000 partners
making over $100,000 a year.
And to us, this means more
people can come on the
platform, create content and
quit their day jobs or
whatever they were
doing before.
And then, one last stat
I want to highlight.
So recently, Nielsen announced
that in the US, we reach more
18 to 34-year-olds than any
other cable network.
So if you think about how your
customers are shifting to
mobile and how they're shifting
online, this is
pretty critical, that you
actually have a presence on
YouTube, where this target
audience for you, potentially,
these 18 to 34-year-olds, are
spending time watching video
and sharing.
OK.
So there's a huge audience
on YouTube.
And they're watching
and sharing videos.
And key audiences for businesses
like yours, the 18
to 34-year-olds, are coming
online to view video.
So why does this actually
matter?
Why are we here talking
about it?
We believe fundamentally, and
we've seen examples that will
show, that sight, sound and
motion is really the best way
to communicate your value to
users and build a longer term
relationship.
So that sounds really abstract,
but let me talk
about what I mean.
So I'm going to tell
three stories.
The first story is, the other
day my friend Douglas shared a
video with me.
And I'm going to play
it quickly.
And then we'll talk about why
it's relevant for all
businesses and what we
can learn from it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
All right.
So why did Douglas share
this video with me?
What's interesting about this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
LANE SHACKLETON: So most of us
don't seek out dental content
on YouTube like this.
But there are two things that
I think are relevant for all
businesses.
One is, this is really
the target audience.
They're reaching the
target audience
with relevant content.
So at the time, "Teach me how
to Dougie" was hot, the song
"Teach me how to Dougie." And
instead of creating a boring
video about how flossing is
important or brushing your
teeth is important, they got
in the middle of the
conversation with those
teenagers that they were
trying to reach.
And I think this is something
that all businesses, again,
can learn from.
So remember, be relevant.
And when you can,
be entertaining.
There are lots of companies,
large and small.
They range from small start-ups
like Dollar Shave
Club all the way to established
brands like Oreo.
And the common thread between
all of them is that they're
following the trends.
They're being relevant to
conversations that are
happening outside of their
given industry.
OK.
Second story.
So last week I was going out
to dinner with my wife.
And I walked into the living
room, and she has a laptop
next to her and a scarf
in her hand, and she's
watching this video.
So let me play just a snippet of
this video, and then we'll
talk about what other marketers
can learn from this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
A.J. CRANE: Hm.
Oh.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK RESUMES]
LANE SHACKLETON: Thankfully,
that video played.
So this video is created by a
company here in San Francisco
called ModCloth.
And ModCloth sells things like
dresses and scarves.
But the other thing that they
do, in addition to selling
products, is that they create
great, fun, quick how-to
content like this.
So in this case, my wife wanted
to know how to tie the
scarf that she had bought that
day into something cool that
she could wear to dinner.
So again, ModCloth creating that
content that she'll come
back to later because she learns
to trust the brand for
how-to type content.
So keep in mind, as a business
owner, you're likely the
expert in your field.
I think we forget that sometimes
as business owners.
Teach people about your
area of expertise.
You know more than a lot
of users about it.
And that's a great opportunity
to build
credibility with your audience.
And I actually really believe
that this is one of the
easiest ways for businesses
to start creating content,
whether it's demoing an app or
whether it's showing your
product in an interesting way.
This is something that most
businesses can do, and we've
seen everyone from Airbnb to
Shopify to RevZilla get in the
middle of these conversations
by teaching something that
people already wanted
to know how to do.
OK, final story.
So my friend, Hunter, loves
sharing videos.
I think we all have friends like
that, that send us too
many videos.
And awhile back, he shared this
video with me, and it's
about skateboarding.
So I want to show just
a snippet of this.
And then, again, we'll talk
about why it's relevant for
all businesses.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
LANE SHACKLETON: All right.
So why did my friend Hunter
share this video with me?
And why did I end up sharing
it with my friends?
Because it's interesting.
It's inspirational.
For those of us that love
getting outside and doing
alternative sports, this is
something that inspires us to
go do that, right?
And it's in video form, with
sight, sound and motion.
Well, There's two other things
I want to call out about this
video that break the
mold a little bit.
One, it's over six
minutes long.
So traditionally, business
owners have thought, I have 15
or 30 seconds to tell
my message.
And look, it's great to tell
your message quickly.
But this is an example of longer
form content that users
actually seek out and
try to watch.
And they also share it with
their friends, because it's
good content.
Secondly, and I'm not sure if
you caught this, but in the
title card, it said Part Four.
So the interesting thing about
this is that Original
Skateboards, they're creating
episodic content.
This isn't just one viral
video or something.
Right?
They're creating a whole
series of videos.
So as a user, I know I'm
watching part four.
But I can come back to the
channel again and again and
get the other episodes.
OK, so remember, when you can,
tell inspiring stories.
Every business has a story, and
some of the best videos
that we see from business owners
are explaining to users
why they matter.
And there are plenty of
examples, like Dove and GoPro
and TRX that do this
exceptionally well.
So if you're looking for
ideas, check them out.
OK, so there are lots of
different types of content
that you can create
as a business.
And we've seen them all.
But here are just three that
we've seen succeed with
businesses both small
and large.
So first, be relevant to
conversations that people are
having outside of
your industry.
I think sometimes we get
a little insulated.
And second, show people
something that they want to
know how to do.
Demo your product in
an interesting
way, or teach something.
Third, I think there's a huge
opportunity to inspire people.
This aspirational content
is a great way to
draw users back in.
OK, so why did we just
talk about content?
Fundamentally, we believe that
creating great content is the
foundation for success as
a business on YouTube.
And I encourage you, when you
think about your normal
content strategy or how your
marketing strategy works, to
think about video and creating
content that feels more like
the other content on YouTube
and less like a commercial.
So A.J. Is going to walk you
through some tactics and bring
up a special guest and talk
through what it looks like to
build your presence on YouTube
after you've created content.
A.J. CRANE: Thanks.
So having great content
is clearly the
most important thing.
But there's some other
optimizations you can make to
make sure that people are
finding your content and to
make sure that your
subscribers are staying engaged.
So we've actually bucketed these
two, these tips, into
two buckets.
First, we'll start with
optimizations you can make to
get your channel set
up and running.
And then, second, we'll talk
about some activities you can
think about on an ongoing, maybe
weekly basis, to make
sure that people are
staying engaged.
So for this first part, we
actually have one of our top
channels in the audience.
And they've been kind enough to
let us set up their channel
in the new One Channel design
which launched in March.
And we'll also show you guys
some other tips too.
So I wanted to bring up Scott
from Original Skateboards.
[APPLAUSE]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SCOTT: I get music?
A.J. CRANE: Thanks.
SCOTT: Thanks for
having me, guys.
A.J. CRANE: Awesome.
Yeah.
Thanks for coming up.
So before we get started, it
would be great if you could
just tell the audience a little
bit about Original
Skateboards and how you guys got
started on the platform.
SCOTT: Well, I mean, we've
been around since 2002.
And I think since the beginning,
we really loved
three things.
We loved skateboarding, making
skateboards and watching
skateboarding videos.
So we started in my parents'
garage when I was 19.
And we kind of did things the
old fashioned way for about
five years.
We were cruising around,
stopping at every surf and
skate shop we could find and
sleeping in a van sometimes,
down by the river in
between motels.
But it was really hard
to get the word out.
It took a long time to drive up
and down the east coast and
all the way out here,
out west.
And we met some really
great people.
But at some point, we realized
that we actually wanted to
create stuff that we could
watch ourselves.
So we had been watching
skateboard
videos all of our lives.
But we really didn't have
any of ourselves.
So we actually started creating
videos not for
YouTube, because this was
before YouTube existed.
The first videos we created with
Nick Patrick, who's our
amazing videographer,
They were for us.
So when we finally did
find out about
YouTube, we had the content.
And the content was set up as
something that we loved.
So your harshest critic is
always going to be yourself.
So we'd been really critiquing
a lot of this stuff.
And by the time we found
someplace, that happened to be
YouTube, to upload it,
it was about 2007.
And we uploaded it and were
really questioning whether or
not anyone would
ever watch it.
And I think about 700 people
watched it that day.
And we were jumping
up and down.
It was insane.
700 people.
Do you know how many
people that is?
So, yeah, and then the next
day, we were all like, oh
that's great.
So a bunch of people
watched it.
But that's not going to
help pay the bills.
And the next day we woke up, and
we had two orders, which
was totally different because
we never really
sold anything at night.
So we were like, hey where
did those come from?
That's kind of weird.
Must be just a strange
coincidence.
But the same thing happened
that day.
And pretty much, that day, our
business went up 40% overall.
And it never went down.
It's like, every day it went
up just a little bit more.
And it took us a little while
to figure out that that was
pretty much due to YouTube.
But what was happening is I
think people were connecting
to our content because we loved
it and we were really
creating something that we
connected to personally.
So when you found someone
through YouTube that was like
us, they connected to it also.
And then that just brought us
closer together with the
people that supported us.
And we started building
this little community.
And now, here we are with
500,000 subscribers,
hopefully, tomorrow, which
is just totally
insane, totally nuts.
A.J. CRANE: Awesome.
Cool.
Well, thanks so much.
So why don't we get started?
SCOTT: Yeah.
Let's do it.
A.J. CRANE: Cool.
OK, so the first thing that
we're going to, I guess we can
take a seat.
The first thing we're going to
set up is video branding.
So most often, people will come
to your videos because
someone shared it or
they found the
video through a search.
So when people are landing
directly on your videos, it's
really important that your
brand shines through
right in the video.
Because they may not have seen
your channel, of course.
So we recently launched a new
feature that makes this really
easy to do.
It's called InVideo
programming.
And what it allows you to do is
overlay either your channel
icon or your logo directly
on all of your videos.
And it's interactive.
So when someone clicks on it,
they can go directly back to
your channel and find more
videos to watch or subscribe.
So the great thing about doing
this through the tool versus
burning it into your videos is
that it's interactive, which I
already mentioned, and that if
your logo ever changes for
whatever reason, you
won't need to
reupload all of your videos.
You can just change it
en masse, at once.
So Scott's team was kind enough
to provide a logo
beforehand.
So here we are in the InVideo
programming interface.
And we can feature
your channel.
So by default, it will show
your channel icon here.
But as I mentioned, you can
also upload a custom logo.
SCOTT: Hopefully transparent.
A.J. CRANE: Yeah, transparent
will look better.
And there we go.
So then, we just need
to answer a
couple of other questions.
You can choose to display
it in any corner.
Which one do you like?
SCOTT: Probably top
right's good.
I don't think that's going to
go over the title card.
So that's good.
A.J. CRANE: Nice.
And then, you can choose to have
it show in the beginning
or for the whole thing.
SCOTT: Probably the whole
thing, assuming that it
doesn't go over the
title card.
A.J. CRANE: Perfect.
OK.
So that's done.
So let's check it out, back In
this video that we are playing
now it's really easy for anyone
to get back to your
videos, or to your
channel page.
So if branding your videos is
really important, probably the
next most important thing is
branding your channel page.
So we launched a new feature
with the OneChannel design
called Channel Art.
And the coolest thing about
Channel Art is it
works on all devices.
And this is actually a big
upgrade from the previous
design, where branding was
really only a desktop feature.
So I actually took a few
screenshots of the Original
Skateboards channel in the
current old design.
And as you can see here, the
brand really doesn't transfer
through to the other devices.
And that's our fault, because
the asset really
only works on desktop.
It's kind of the gutters.
And there are no gutters
on mobile or on TV.
So we thought about maybe
offering different images for
each platform.
But that wasn't going to work
either, that would be kind of
a moving target, with
new devices
coming out every month.
We'd have to constantly
hound people like
Scott for new assets.
And no one would like that.
SCOTT: And we probably wouldn't
get them done.
A.J. CRANE: So instead, we've
designed Channel Art to be a
single simple asset that can be
cropped and scaled to work
on all devices.
So let's set that up
on your channel.
SCOTT: Sounds good.
A.J. CRANE: So the first
thing we'll do is opt
into the new design.
So ready to do it?
SCOTT: Yeah, let's change it.
A.J. CRANE: OK.
So this is your channel
in the new design.
The first thing it's asking
us to do is to add
this channel art.
So you can really easily
choose the
image you guys created.
SCOTT: And it was
actually great.
We are lucky enough to have
a great designer.
But there's some really awesome
guidelines that you
can look up on how to actually
create art like this, so that
it scales and works
really well.
A.J. CRANE: So here, you
get a quick preview.
So you get an idea of how this
image is going to be used on
all three devices.
And as Scott mentioned,
there's also templates
available if you want to
make it pixel perfect.
So let's apply the image.
And there we go.
So I'm assuming you guys
probably want to drive people
back to OriginalSkateboards.com
in
case they want to buy a board.
SCOTT: That would be good.
Or come and check out our
dealer list and find a
skateboard shop near them
and then go buy a board.
A.J. CRANE: OK, so we can
overlay a link back to their
website by going to the About
tab and checking this box to
overlay the first link
on their channel art.
So there we go.
So now their channel
art is all set up.
And it should be working
across all devices.
So we've branded the videos
and branded the channel.
So next let's organize
your content.
So the primary goal of this
channel page, other than
showing your brand, is obviously
to help viewers find
your videos and get them to
watch more of your content.
So the new channel design has
a feature called Sections,
which make it really easy to
see the different types of
content and for your viewers
to browse and find
something to watch.
So let's add a couple sections
to your channel.
So how do you guys think about
what kinds of content do you
want to feature?
SCOTT: I mean, we actually
do a lot of
different kinds of videos.
I mean, everything from the
ride inspiration, like you
just get people excited to go
out and have fun like you guys
showed earlier in "Go
Longboard," to a travel series
to informational videos
about the product.
A.J. CRANE: So put "Go
Longboard" on there?
SCOTT: Yeah, definitely.
It's episodic and by far our
most viral series, for sure.
A.J. CRANE: All right.
And then you also mentioned
the viral videos.
SCOTT: Yeah, definitely.
That kind of has videos other
than "Go Longboard" in it, but
it does include "Go
Longboard" also.
So that's perfect, too.
A.J. CRANE: Cool.
And then, the last
one was the--
SCOTT: Yeah, we have the Product
Checkouts playlist,
which is just a great place to
go and walk through what makes
our boards special.
So I think that's a really great
one to have up there.
A.J. CRANE: Awesome.
So which one do you
want to be on top?
SCOTT: Probably Viral Videos
first, and then Product
Checkouts second, and
then "Go Longboard."
A.J. CRANE: Perfect.
All right.
So there you go.
So now all this content's layed
out in a really easy to
browse fashion.
And viewers can come and scroll
through this and really
easily find the next video
they want to watch.
So if getting viewers to watch
videos is our primary goal, a
very close second here is
getting them to subscribe.
Subscribers to your channel
are going to watch more of
your videos and they're going
to come back to your channel
more often.
So it's really worth
it to invest in
getting people to subscribe.
So the best way that we
can do this is by
showing them a video.
So the new channel design has
a video player that only
appears to unsubscribed
viewers.
So this gives you the
opportunity to play a video
that can really pitch people on
why they should subscribe.
So Scott's team created
a trailer.
So let's add this in.
This one?
SCOTT: Yeah.
And hey, we just put it live
and it's already maxed the
view count out.
So that's a good sign.
A.J. CRANE: We literally
just put this live
like 10 minutes ago.
300 views.
That's awesome.
All right.
So let's take a look at this.
SCOTT: Yeah, it should just be
some, a little bit of skating,
a little bit of everything.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
A.J. CRANE: Awesome.
SCOTT: So it's a little
difficult to tell a story in
30 seconds.
But we tried to do our best.
A.J. CRANE: No.
I'm going to subscribe.
And--
SCOTT: Cool.
A.J. CRANE: --we can see how
effective this is by checking
the number of attendees
verses new
subscribers after the session.
SCOTT: Definitely check that.
A.J. CRANE: Awesome.
So now the channel's
all set up.
All we had to do was set up the
branding in the videos on
the page, organize
your content and
then upload the trailer.
One other thing I wanted to note
here is, so the trailer
is great for people
who aren't yet
familiar with your content.
But for people who are already
subscribed, the freshest,
newest content is always
important to them.
So they want to see videos
they haven't seen yet.
So if you want to check out what
your channel's going to
look like to people who are
subscribed, you can use this
toggle here.
And you'll see that a subscriber
will get a
personalized recommendation of
what they should watch next
based on what they've
already seen.
So that will be really helpful
for getting more views from
your subscribers.
SCOTT: Yeah, it looks great.
Definitely.
I'm really excited.
I mean I can't believe we
finally have a layout that's
going to work in mobile.
Which is totally worth
sacrificing the gutters.
Absolutely.
A.J. CRANE: Awesome.
So I took some screenshots of,
now that we've uploaded the
channel art, what it looks like
across all three devices.
So you can now see the contrast
between a desktop
only branded channel page versus
something that works on
all devices.
SCOTT: And TVs.
A.J. CRANE: And TV.
Coming soon.
SCOTT: Yes.
A.J. CRANE: Great.
Thanks so much, Scott.
SCOTT: Yeah, thanks for
having me, guys.
A.J. CRANE: It's been great
having you guys up here and--
SCOTT: Yeah.
Hey, thanks for having us.
A.J. CRANE: Be sure to check out
the Original Skateboards
sandbox after this, if you
guys have any additional
questions for Scott.
OK, so you guys all saw how to
set up a channel and get off
the ground.
Next I wanted to talk through
some ongoing activities that
you guys can think about
on a weekly basis.
So first and foremost, the most
important thing you can
do on YouTube is make
sure you're
engaging with your fans.
The YouTube audience loves an
open line of communication.
And they love the fact that they
can talk freely with the
creators of the content
that they love.
So make sure that you're taking
advantage of that.
Here you can see one of my
favorite channels, "Hilah in
the Kitchen." And she
famously responds to
her comments instantly.
And you can see here
that she's even
getting kudos for that.
Think of someone commenting on
your video, like someone
walking into your store.
If they have a question for
you, you should be able to
respond back immediately and
help make that sale or help
answer whatever question
they may have.
In addition to commenting on
videos, there's also a
discussion tab that you
can enable right on
your channel page.
And this is a great place for
your fans to be able to leave
ideas for you or comments
on your channel.
And you can see here that Hilah
gets tons of ideas for
her next video.
And so fans will openly give you
ideas for your next video.
Here she's got recommendations
to do gluten free videos and
vegan videos.
So thinking of new ideas
for videos is hard.
And so having this constant
stream of ideas coming in from
your fans is a really, really
helpful resource.
And the more you act on
that, the more your
fans will engage further.
So another great way to get
your audience involved is
through Google+ Hangouts.
So some of our creators on
YouTube have been using these
in really, really
creative ways.
And I wanted to share two
of my favorite examples.
So this first one, "Pocketnow,"
is a tech
reviewing channel.
And they do a series every
week called "You Review,"
where they will invite 10 of
their audience members or
their fans to join in on the
Hangout, and then they'll all
review the same product
at the same time.
So here they're reviewing
the Galaxy S4.
And this is kind of like a
modern take on the talk show.
And so that's been a really
interesting example to see.
Another totally different way
of using Hangouts is to do
user support and Q&A. So one of
our channels, "Indy Mogul,"
who targets kind of amateur
filmmakers, he does a live Q&A
where he'll get some of his
fans on who have questions
about how to recreate a specific
effect, and he'll
answer it right then and there
and broadcast it on his
channel, knowing that there's
probably someone else out
there that has the same
question and he can
help them out too.
So it's key that you make sure
that you're posting new stuff
to your channel page
very regularly.
Because when you post something,
it shows up on the
homepage of your subscribers.
And make sure that you're kind
of remaining top of mind for
the people that are subscribed
to your channel.
So it's really hard to come up
with a new video to upload
every week, or even
every other week.
So a great way to kind of fill
the gaps between uploads and
make sure that you're posting
fresh content
is to curate content.
And so you can curate content
by liking other people's
videos, posting other videos,
or even adding
other videos to playlists.
So GoPro actually does
a great job of this.
They have a playlist called "Fan
Favorites," and they will
find a new fan video uploaded
and created on a GoPro and add
it to their "Fan Favorites"
video playlist every week.
So I know what you guys
are thinking.
Of course GoPro can do this.
They make a camera, and there's
probably lots of user
generated content out there.
But it's not only GoPro
that does this.
I noticed the other day on the
Intel channel that they also
have a Fan Favorites playlist.
And check out the first
video in the playlist.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
A.J. CRANE: So having someone
make a video about your brand
is the highest compliment you
can receive, even if they're
replacing your really expensive
marketing content
with a screaming goat.
So you can't be a bitter
person about this.
You need to join in with the fun
and embrace the fact that
people are creating
user generated
content about your brand.
And the YouTube community will
really appreciate this and
respond well to it.
You can even see that here,
Intel responded to this
uploader in a humorous way.
So for those of you who don't
know, goats that scream like
humans were actually huge on
YouTube a couple months ago.
And it seemed as though every
video that had a goat in it
was really successful, and the
related video action was
pretty good too.
So how do you find out
about these trends?
We have a resource for that.
It's called the Trends
Dashboard, YouTube.com/trends.
And this is a blog that's
curated by YouTubers and
follows the latest trending
topics on the site.
And it includes data and also
some live examples.
So this is a great way to find
out what may be resonating
with this core YouTube
audience.
But of course you don't need to
be following the trends in
order to be successful
on YouTube.
Another way to find success
is to kind of nurture and
understand your niche
or core audience.
Looking into YouTube Analytics
is probably the best way to
find out who your audience
really is.
Sometimes you'll be surprised.
For example, I recently
discovered that on my own
channel, I have more
viewers in Poland
than any other country.
So who knew?
But there's tons of other really
cool reports here.
There's demographic report,
playback locations, and an
audience retention report which
lets you know which
parts of your video
are most engaging.
So this is a really great way
to learn what you should be
doing more of or maybe what you
should be doing less of.
So lastly, I'm going to hand it
back over to Lane to talk
for a little bit about how you
can promote your videos.
LANE SHACKLETON: Great.
So once you've got great content
and you've set up your
channel, one thing that you may
want to do that businesses
often do is promote their
content through paid
advertising.
So in this case, GoPro is
using a format that we
released called Trueview
In-stream.
And what Trueview In-stream
tries to do is balance the
need of the user with
the advertiser.
So you may have noticed
these on the site.
They've been there for awhile.
There's a skip button
on the ad.
So the user gets a choice
in the ad experience.
If they don't like the ad or
they're not interested, they
just hit skip.
And on the advertiser side, they
don't actually pay if the
user skips.
So the advertiser only pays if
someone watches the video,
which creates the right set
of incentives on the site.
And there's a really easy
way to set this up
if you're on YouTube.
So if you go to the YouTube
Video Manager and you're
managing your videos, you
just click Promote.
And you'll be dropped into
this little tool.
This tool leads you to create an
AdWords for Video Campaign.
And it's a three step process.
And you tell us what video you
want to promote, what audience
you want to reach and
what your budget is.
And then we'll go out and show
this video to those users and
help you build a long term
audience of viewers and
subscribers.
A.J. CRANE: Great, thanks.
So we shared a lot of
information with you guys.
So I just wanted to recap
really quickly.
Tips for setting up
your channel.
Make sure that you're branding
your videos and branding your
actual channel page.
Organize your content in a way
that makes it easy for people
to browse and find
what to watch.
Create a trailer so that you
can convert unsubscribed
visitors to subscribers.
And then, on an ongoing basis,
making sure that you're
engaging with your community
through comments, discussion
and through Google+ Hangouts.
Curate fan content using likes
or playlists to fill the gap
between uploads.
Making sure you're staying on
top of the trends with the
Trends Dashboard.
Keeping an eye on your numbers
through YouTube Analytics to
find out who your audience
really is.
And then also, thinking about
promoting your videos.
So all these tips are
really important.
But not as important as making
sure that you're creating
great content, which Lane talked
about at the beginning.
So content is king on YouTube.
And all of these things will
help you get more visibility,
but content is really the
most important thing.
So lastly, we just wanted
to leave you
guys with a few resources.
There's the Creator Hub, which
has more case studies and
examples of successful stories
on YouTube, the Creator
Playbook, which has a checklist
of basically
everything we discussed today
and more, Trends Dashboard for
finding out what's hot on
YouTube right now, and the Ads
Leader board which has some
really great examples of
content from small businesses
and marketers that have been
successful.
and lastly--
/advertise and /dev for both
of those audiences.
Cool.
So lastly, we just wanted to
open it up to questions.
And feel free to direct
questions at us or also at
Scott from Original
Skateboards.
LANE SHACKLETON: And
please use the mic.
AUDIENCE: Hey, so I have a
question about promotions.
So one of the things I've
noticed, both with my own
channel and other people who
I've helped do the marketing
portion of their channels,
is that when you set up a
promotional campaign, sometimes
it takes days and
days before it actually
gets approved.
Is there any way to speed
up that process?
LANE SHACKLETON: We are
very sorry about that.
AUDIENCE: And it's very
unpredictable.
Sometimes it's less than an hour
turnaround, and sometimes
it's almost a week.
LANE SHACKLETON: So we
also noticed this.
And we kicked off a whole
team that is looking at
this within the team.
So we have over three people
working on this right now, and
we're about to launch some
really cool stuff that will
actually speed up that approval
process significantly
in the coming months.
AUDIENCE: And so the other thing
I've noticed about that
is that it doesn't seem to
matter how much money you're
willing to spend.
Because you can have an
AdWords rep for your
pay-per-click spend, and it's
completely ignored.
They're two separate universes,
seemingly.
LANE SHACKLETON: Yeah.
We feel your pain.
And we absolutely want to
solve that problem.
It's in our, both of
our best interests.
AUDIENCE: With the integration
more of the Google+ assets,
Hangout and so forth, with
YouTube, what's the best
method to get your subscribers
basically
hooked into +1 [? U-1 ?]
on G+?
A.J. CRANE: So the question is,
what's the best way to get
a subscriber also hooked
in to follow on G+?
Well, if you do link accounts,
your Google+ page will
automatically be linked
from your channel.
So that's a great way to drive
people back and forth.
To get someone else to follow
you on Google+, you could use
in-video annotations.
The best way is usually to ask
people in your video to follow
you on Google+.
And you can always link from
underneath the video.
But the actions currently are
still separate, subscribing
and following.
I forgot to mention, too, on
the channel art, that your
channel art is actually the
same specs as your Google+
page artwork.
So you can use the same image
in both locations.
AUDIENCE: I'm Mark
from Pixability.
I'm wondering about an API
for promoting videos.
Is that coming any time
soon in the timeline?
And we can talk about
this offline.
LANE SHACKLETON: Sure.
So enabling the features that
are involved in an API, things
like bulk editing, are certainly
something that we
care a lot about.
I think it's worth mentioning,
when you think about AdWords
for Video, it's still an
incredibly nascent platform.
So it was launched literally
about April 2012.
So from our perspective, we want
to make sure that we're
doing a great job for small,
medium, large users before we
focus on some of those
external APIs.
One thing that we're launching
very soon is CSV import.
So you've probably heard this.
You're smiling.
So we plan to release this to
enable some of those bulk
editing functions.
And an API is certainly
something that
we're thinking about.
But I don't have anything
to announce here.
AUDIENCE: OK.
We're very happy to give you
feedback for that API.
And also to do some
data testing.
LANE SHACKLETON: I'd be glad
to hear that feedback.
AUDIENCE: Cheers, thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
It costs money to
create a video.
And then I'm interested
in ROI.
LANE SHACKLETON: Yeah.
That's a great question.
So how many people saw the video
that later downloaded?
So I'll actually connect
you with a mobile
person after this.
But one of the things that we
are thinking about is how to
enable people to understand
moving from videos into apps
and app downloads.
That's not a use case that
we've nailed yet.
I'll be frank with you.
But it is, I think that's
a case that we should be
thinking more about.
And I believe there's also
something on the mobile side
that can be done.
But I'd like to--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LANE SHACKLETON: Yeah, certainly
you can use things
like annotations to drive
people to that video.
I'm just thinking of actually
linking that download back to
the specific video view.
I'm probably not the
expert there.
Actually, we're out of time.
AUDIENCE: Actually, a couple of
hacks for that would be to
provide a unique link in the
description and also buy
enough of a promotional campaign
so you get the call
to action overlay, and then
track them that way.
LANE SHACKLETON: Yeah, certainly
a unique URL is a
great way to do that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LANE SHACKLETON: Yeah it's
worth investing.
We're actually out of time.
So let's follow up after.
Thank you so much.
A.J. CRANE: Yeah.
Thanks for coming!